look here with the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and I'm about to restore the
most beautiful acts I've ever seen
[Music]
alright guys so we're gonna do another
acts restoration video here and this
one's really a fun look in X it's in
really great shape as far as corrosion
and pitting is concerned but it's got
some unusual problems with it let me
show you what I'm talking about very
little rust almost no pitting a little
bit of like flaking on the surface
beautiful maker's mark but there's some
mushrooming on the sides and there's
this look at this there's it looks
almost like this was cast rather than
forged and there was like a little bit
of spill over in the process so gotta
get rid of this and check this out see
right here that is not flat that it's
got a serious bow in the blade so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna heat this
thing up in the Forge I'm gonna take a
chisel and try to knock this stuff out
and I'm going to try to bend this flat
and then I'm going to heat treat it and
we're gonna go from there
[Music]
so there we go knocked out the slag
inside the hole now we got to straighten
it out
alright we got the blade straightened
out looks pretty good
now we're gonna heat the whole thing up
and heat treat it
[Music]
[Music]
oh you son of a gun how do you see what
you're doing there oh what a mess
melted a hole right my bucket dumped
about four quarts of motor oil on my
driveway time to go buy some kitty
litter now that this axe is heat treated
I'm gonna knock off all the scale and
carbon and smooth out the scratches get
it all polished a lot of you'll be
wondering why I'm not tempering it in an
oven and that's because tempering is a
process used to help soften steel that
is too brittle and too hard currently I
have no reason to believe that that is
the case with this steel and if I'm
wrong it'll make an interesting video
oh alright so sharpening that axe with
the file got me I was going back and
forth and went ding and just hit it
right on the tip of my pinky right on
the blade you gotta be pretty pretty
deep but I don't think I need the
stitches I can't see any fat or anything
down there
one down nine to go
slice my finger pretty darn good on that
uh that axe so it's definitely getting
pretty sharp I'm gonna do a little bit
more filing and then I've got to start
sharpening it properly with an actual
honing stone but it's getting dark I
still haven't quite stopped bleeding
let's call it a day for today well it is
a cold December day I'm gonna pick up
where I left off when I sliced up my
pinky I am going to keep working on
grinding out some of the imperfections
in the axe and I'm going to be putting
that bevel in well as you can see this
side looks pretty darn good I just got a
few little spots here and there to grind
out but most of the work needs to be
done on this side
well guys I'm learning from my mistakes
they put some tape on the edge here to
keep me from cutting myself again while
polishing this thing up
[Music]
[Music]
oh I burned through a lot of sandpaper
well the Sun is setting and it's getting
late I think is a good place to stop for
right now I'm going to start working on
the handle and sharpening my axe next so
still quite a few things to do but this
is turning out really well so I've got a
little problem and I've got my good
friend Matt here who's gonna help me fix
it the the hole in my axe head is too
wide for this piece of lumber here so I
need to go and get two pieces and
sandwich them together to make a
slightly wider handle unfortunately I do
not have the tools for that and doing it
by hand is a skill I do not possess so
Matt here is going to help me plane them
right that's a join them and join them
and play them so and we've got this
piece of zebra wood right here which
we're gonna use for the handle and then
I've got some other pieces they've been
sitting around in my this morado and
I've got some Purple Heart wood and
stuff that may make a cameo in some
future videos so you put a little pencil
scribbles on here and then it lets you
know any place it didn't get planed yep
sweet good trick
let zebrawood school is it
[Music]
we've got the two pieces of zebra wood
and you can see they make nice
symmetrical pattern there it's gonna be
very very pretty
they'll use some water resistant glue
here got it all clamped up plenty of
wood glue view this 24 hours to cure and
we'll go from there it's been about four
or five days since I put this project
down my wife just had our third child
little Jacob I'll put a link in the
description if you want to see some
ridiculously cute baby videos moving
forward I've got to sketch out the
outline of the ax handle and do a lot of
cutting and grinding and we're gonna
shape this bad boy up and see how it
looks
[Music]
man that doesn't look too bad at all
does it
we're gonna clean up a little around
here then I gotta sand this handle down
then we got to mount this all right got
a little spring steel left over from a
previous project I'm gonna really quick
Forge this into the shape of some wedges
to put in the top of the axe handle
there we go got a little wedge made and
I'm just gonna do a quick blue this with
a map gas torch
[Applause]
there we go we got the wedge blued so
it's less likely to corrode all right
I've got a piece of African mahogany
here I'm gonna use to make a wedge and I
could use a piece of zebra wood but it's
all got this lamination spot in the
middle to make it kind of weak so I can
use this piece of African mahogany as a
wedge instead got the wedge done nice
and thin I gotta tell you guys that I
was glad to be inside 16 degrees was the
high a little nippy out there that is
gorgeous oh it is smooth to the touch
it feels like it's lacquered that 2,000
grit sandpaper really puts the polish on
it now normally this is all I'll do I'll
just slap on some linseed oil and call
it good and wood will keep really well
that way so you can see here here's some
handles where I've done just that and
they look amazing
but this is laminated wood and I'm
worried about how weather and rain and
stuff might delaminate it so I'm gonna
seal it with polyurethane and put on
several coats to try to protect this
handle because I really want to use an
abusive
there we go the zebrawood handle is
complete now I just need to mount the
axe head on it all right well I did
something that's got me a little
irritated at myself okay so normally you
put a metal wedge in right there in the
middle across the top I've really
worried about splitting the wood and so
I slid the metal wedge in the back but
it was such a big wedge it raised it up
there so what I should have done is
gotten two smaller wedges and put one in
the front one in the back and then
pounded them in together it is what it
is but eventually this wedge will
probably work itself out eventually you
start to get a little bit loose when it
does I can pull it out I can redo it the
way I want and it'll be fine
but it it is on there super tight man
now what I want to do is I want to do
some wet forming where you get some
leather wet and you mold it around the
axe for a very snug contoured sheath in
order to do that I need to create a
spacer because you don't want the sheath
to be the exact same size as the Hatcher
you want a little gap so that'll come in
and out easily all right
all right so I got my axe saran-wrapped
with a piece of cardboard on the back
I've got a piece of wood here now to go
soak some leather all right get some
water
and put the leather in it so after only
being in the water for like a minute or
two you can see it's very flexible and
pliable exactly what you want all right
there we go it's actually been a couple
days now and the leathers dried up very
nicely you can see here it's hard and it
it's really well to the axe so we're
gonna take the nails off and we're gonna
draw the outline of the sheath and get
going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all I got left to do is put this snap on
right there but the snaps I have
unfortunately our antique brass instead
of shiny brass and they don't really
match so I'm gonna get some shiny brass
snaps and in the meantime I'm gonna dye
this thing
it's been a couple days and look at that
sheet this is looking good
got my snaps in the man just need to
drill a hole here drill a hole here
install the snap and then I need to coat
the outside of this and beeswax to
protect it and seal it we're gonna be
good to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well look at that that is absolutely
gorgeous and I'm just so pleased with
this that handle is amazing look at that
mirror finish and that is awesome man
this thing is gorgeous
but can it cut let's uh let's go try it
out
well guys this was an awesome project I
just really enjoyed this one and I love
how it turned out there's definitely
some things I would do differently if
that wedge ever starts coming out I am
anxious to reset that axe head so it's a
little bit more flush and a little bit
more proper but hey you know that's
that's part of the fun is learning
something new and getting better each
time you do it so definitely definitely
enjoyed this project it was a wall I'm
proud of that I really am thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor voice youtube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button so
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video